welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of the
Mandalorian season 3 episode 2 chapter
18 the minds of Mandalore where spoiler
morning the mythosar is no longer a myth
let's break down this episode scene by
scene where all the Star Wars Easter
eggs the details you missed and the
Mystery of the mythosar cause yeah we
got questions also subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive with even more
pointed analyzes of the titles you'd
love and you can support this growing
Network by grabbing some merch at nerd
riot.shop like our new madeleorn
inspired the way collection we open on
Tatooine in the city of Maz Eisley land
Speeders racing the streets as fireworks
pop overhead
[Music]
they're using the same sound effect from
the pod racers drifting in Phantom
Menace
this race is part of the bunta Eve
celebration a holiday celebrated on
Tatooine with pod racing tournaments it
was actually the reason behind the
Padres that led to Anakin's Freedom
there's big race tomorrow on Boom to Eve
Boon to Eve celebrates bhunta histilic
shadru who is a Hut who ascended into
godhood in the town of my size layover
on the left you could see another
speeder doing donuts in another
Courtyard red banner suspended over the
Alleyways meanwhile of the two racing
Speeders the one in the lead bumps into
the side and stalls out allowing the one
trailing him to take the lead Amy
Sedaris returns as pelimoto ripping off
a rhodian perpetroids carry a pole this
is the same prop we saw the last time we
were here in the book of Boba Fett
chapter five this is the same poll that
Han Solo used to try to embrace the
trash compactor walls on the Death Star
to New Hope among her droids is also a
BD unit Droid the same type as bd1
calcasus's companion and Jedi Fallen
order in the upcoming Jedi Survivor and
a reminder that this red Astromech r5d4
is the same one with the busted
motivator that the job was trying to
sell to Luca Nicole Owen pelly tells the
Jawas to paint the stolen parts from
this same speeder so that they look
different maintain the parts to look
different that is what the Mandalorian
Clan is doing with their best guard
pieces to differentiate each other their
best car was stolen from them in the
purge and now they are in a process of
reassembling their multicolored
fragments into something that can work
together collectively rogu leaps out of
the cockpit and pelly says he leaps like
a Lerman Lerman are the mammals from
mygito who have appeared a few times in
Clone Wars grogu utters what sounds like
a first word yeah Pele says he said
pelly but it sounded more like bucket or
Beckett Beckett was Woody Harrelson's
character in Solo a star story I don't
think grogu knows him I guess he could
have met him in the early years but
grogu utters a lot of stuff in this
episode he's just babbling up the storm
pelly asks if Dan jarin took on Boba
Fett in the Hutts and if the Hutts are
back referring to the Hutt twins that
Boba Fett negotiated with in the book of
Boba Fett now Pele has a gap in her
teeth because she lost that tooth in the
finale of The Book of Boba Fett
something that Amy Sedaris actually said
was her improvised idea
pelly asks the Jawa as if there's
anywhere they can find an IG unit memory
circuit and she tells din sorry no
chance cubes as in no dice chance cubes
being the red and blue sided dice that
waddo and Qui-Gon used to roll for
Anakin and schmee in Phantom Menace now
IG units were Empire Era assassin droids
now that the Empire's done with there's
not too many IG units left out there
except maybe IG 88 who is the Assassin
in The Empire Strikes Back we don't know
what happened to him he could be out
there somewhere R5 backs away in fear
from Den he trembles and pelly says that
he served in the Rebellion technically
R5 did kind of serve the Rebellion by
intention blowing that motivator at
R2D2's request so that R2 could go to
Luke and Leia's Stone Death Star plans
would make their way to Obi-Wan so RFI
did play an important role there all
this was covered in the red one story
from the Anthology from a certain point
of view as pelly loads them all in later
I love out behind her the pit Droid
swings the trash compactor pull around
or isn't the other one after duck and
eventually this gets smacked in the head
they depart through the Ubuntu e
fireworks and it looks a hell of a lot
better than a similar scene in one Orman
84 is good
but it can be better R.I.P Patty Jenkins
Star Wars movie they made her get in
that flight suit for nothing so as they
approached Mandalore then jarne
describes the planet to grow who's
saying it was once green and beautiful
when the songs were written but he says
he's never actually been there the
service of Mandalore was scorched an
event called the Mandalorian cataclysm
this is long before any of the events
we've seen this was the final war
between the mandalorians and the Jedi
the armor referred to these wars in
chapter 8 from season one the songs of
eons pass tell the battles between
Mandalore the great and an order of
sorcerers called Jedi Mandalore the
great was the first leader of the
Mandalorian people din points to the
Moon of Concordia that's his home in the
home of the death watch that the armor
mentioned in her history of a night of a
thousand Tears In the book of Boba Fett
he also mentions the planet calabala on
the navigation screen which is all part
of the same system din tells grogu that
a Mandalorian has to understand maps
that know their way around and that way
you'll never be lost this sets up how
grogu is able to navigate back to
calabala and I guess R5 helps him out
too but on a deeper level din is
explaining that core to being a
Mandalorian is to be a homeless
diasporatic Wanderer when bogoton told
in last episode go home it was a knowing
insult none of them could really go home
not even Bo Katan and her empty husk of
a castle stretching over the rocky
landscape of the planet are these
massive sections of the turquoise
colored crystal that we saw last episode
a pretty cruel Mirage when you think
about it when you see green you think
it's going to be vegetation but no it's
on the other side of two destructions
this is formed by the Sands of the
planet being melted in the fusion blasts
as R5 rolls over the cave you see some
smart use of the volume here that's the
360 degree LED interior set that they
shoot a lot of these things on notice
there's a wet puddle surface that
reflects the LED screen above showing
the sky but also reflects R5 as he rolls
past they use something practical and
tangible the R5 Droid to blend with what
would otherwise just be a glowing
backdrop making the whole thing just
feel more real to the viewer these kind
of tactics along with characters having
actual emotional connections with their
environments something you can feel even
through their helmets is why I think the
Mandalorian has always gotten better use
out of the volume than the Marvel
Studios titles have when R5 disappears
Mando tells rogu to steal himself in his
pod as Mano checks the atmospheric
conditions telling us that this new
bassinet that din got for grogu is
airtight and has its own breathing
apparatus I mean this thing could
probably go underwater and in space if
it ever comes to that as din walks
around outside you can hear his suits
breathe or inhaling and exhaling putting
us inside of Dan's helmet with him and
giving us some real Darth Vader Vibes
like an overall creepy sensation as
we're exploring the surface Kroger sits
up in the cockpit looking concerned and
den is able to sense this kid's eyes on
him so he turns around to reassure him
dense belongs through this Crystal Cave
bathed in turquoise light from the glass
above giving this descent and Aquatic
feel like Mando is already taking his
first steps into those Living Waters he
looks out over the ruins of the covered
city of sundari its 3D cityscape that we
saw in Clone Wars now covered in debris
but with natural light pouring in like
the helmets worn by the mandalorians of
the watch the mandalorians would encase
their cities in other types of chrome
domes and now a crack in that shell has
forced its way in bringing in this green
symbolically mirroring the way a little
green force of nature Pierce din's
helmet and got him to open up Dan gets
attacked by alamites who carry these
weapons carved out of that same Green
Glass showing how they have adapted to
the new planet's surface din ignites the
darksaber and immediately the blade
lowers in his hands showing how he is
still struggling with the weight of it
as he did in chapter 5 of The Book of
book fit in that butcher shop and while
fighting the armor and past vislove
those scenes hearken back to Rebels
season 3 episode 15 Trials of the
darksaber when Sabine Wren trained with
the darksaber with Kanan Jairus and we
learned one's ability to lift and use
the dark saber effectively is really a
factor of the wielder's connection with
the kyber crystal inside the blade feels
lighter you're connecting with it it's
becoming a part of you so din jar and
still has not fully connected with it so
when he swings he loses control and now
he takes a beating from one of the
alamites dint's only able to fend it off
not with a darksaber but with a vibro
blade of the leg he continues to
pathetically drag the darksaber around
on the ground and really gets most of
his successful hits with punches with
Jabs but he finally stabs the final
alamite and deactivates a lightsaber as
if for leave to turn the thing off and
it leaves vertical slit in the chest a
nice bit of continuity since the
darksaber is a flat blade it's not a
cylindrical saber like other lightsabers
are outside din has R5 run an analysis
on the air and the hollow projection
shows oribesh number 95 I assume the
numbers in orabesh look mostly like
Arabic numerals and din says Bo Katan
was right Mandalore is not cursed
shoulders set him to credit season 2
Boca time from Trask and not the Pokemon
he just talked to last episode who said
that there was nothing for them there
showing that he still believes in the
hopeful Mandalorian inside now watching
something you love is self-care it feels
good right well with geology you can
have that good feeling of self-care in
your daily routine too geology is a
16-time award-winning personalized
skincare company recognized in men's
health Esquire and ask men grooming
Awards with over 6 000 5 Star reviews
just take a quick 30 second diagnostic
quiz and geology will create a simple
and effective skincare or hair care
routine customized just for you with
ingredients that are dermatologist
tested proven to work and personalized
to your needs for Hair Care geology's
got strength in each shampoo and
conditioner co-wash which will transform
you routine and deliver the best hair of
your life it extends the time between
washes and replaces the need for so many
products so you can wash your hair less
and save money they also offer body
washes and deodorants that are free of
harsh ingredients and they smell great
and for skincare they have you covered
from all angles you can fight acne
reduce oil-ness prevent wrinkles combat
darker puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
their daily personalized skincare
routine comes with Too Faced washes
morning face cream retinol night cream
and eye cream and right now for a
limited time you can get a five piece
trial set for only 15 if you use a code
rockstar70 at checkout that's over 50 a
product for just fifteen dollars and on
top of that you'll get an additional
bonus offer of one of their brand new
skin hair and body products of your
choice when you add it to your trial to
get started just click the link in the
description didn't descends using this
jetpack while roku's floating bassinet
can apparently defy any level of gravity
they pass various fauna on their way
down just a little clue that not only
Wildlife exists down here but there is a
food chain and thus something for an
apex predator a mythosar to feed as
Qui-Gon says there's always a bigger
fish and Pokemon actually later says
this episode that alamites used to live
on the wastelands on the outskirts of
the town and so if things can survive
here something else might be able to
survive too din finds this area with
half-buried Mandalorian armor it looked
like gorenson's flute comes back here
[Music]
I love how at first the tea visor forms
the shape of a pickaxe but before we can
even wonder who these mandalorians were
it's revealed to all be a trap from this
creature who seems to have laid all this
armor here as a treasure to Spring the
Trap using the best car armor bones of
past mandalorians who wander down here
to catch future ones this creature is
gnarly he's a fusion mechanized Parts
but one highly expressive menacing eye I
love seeing how all of its insectoid
segments interact with each other its
yellow tubes flopping around as it
chirps like a beetle grogu tries to pry
open the trap with the force but he
draws the captor's attention and flees
as he floats back down this tunnel he
passes the Predator creature that we saw
before and then suddenly snaps his gator
Jaws in the headlight reminding me of
the movie the alien when Dallas crawls
through the Nostromo vent shafts and his
xenomorph suddenly appears in his
flashlight on the way out an alamite
jumps in front of grogu but grogu who's
taken out a mud horn before has no time
for this and forces slaps four
eyes grogu then does a front flip into
the cockpit and that flying predator
that snapped at him before had been
chasing him the whole time as they get
apart I'm not really sure where Goku's
floating pod went on that Starfighter
that's a pretty big bulky pod
starfighters aren't really meant to have
a ton of room for storage R5 pilot sent
back to kalavara and we return to
pokeaton's throne room Bo Katan has
adjusted her sitting position from a
board Lounge to now a bowed head and
here in this shot we do briefly see that
in grave tablu on the other side of the
throne just one figure on the end of it
this may be a peaceful scene from the
history of how squeezed to contrast the
warring Dogpile on the other side
poketon looks out the window and assumes
it's din jarin in the Starfighter it
says let's get rid of him once and for
all yikes does bogoton mean killed in
Jared we're just threatening him so much
he stays away from her forever a
conflict between these two characters is
definitely being set up she was ready to
fight him Pokemon fires up the gauntlet
this is our Comer class fighter from
clone wars and she Pilots down to the
ruins of sundari with a lot more
confidence piloting through that storm
as if she's Revisited the surface before
she looks upon the ruins with shame
telling rogu it didn't always look like
this structurally in this episode I
think it's interesting how grogu walks
this same path but with two different
Mandalorian chaperones it's almost like
getting back to back tours of a haunted
graveyard given first by a guide who
grew up on stories about this place but
then by someone who actually used to
live there in a graveyard uh that
metaphor didn't really make sense but
you get it Pokemon looks out over the
Civic Center and says this was once a
beautiful civilization my family ruled
over it all now it's a tomb she's
referring to her house house Crees her
father at an eye crease who was killed
during the Great Clan Wars which
resulted in the militant traditionalists
getting banished to Concordia and they
became the death watch but when the
father died pocaton's older sister
Duchess sateen Cree succeeded him sateen
was Obi-Wan's ill-fated love who was
killed by Maul with the dark side right
in front of Obi-Wan bogoton tells grogu
I knew quite a few Jedi you know I don't
know what they taught you about us but
there was a time when we actually got
along quite well fought side by side
focus on is referring to a lot of the
past the events of Clone Wars when she
fought alongside Obi-Wan after she left
the death watch and turned on them and
then later in season 7 when she and
Ahsoka Tano retook Mandalore from Maul
and also when bogoton appears in Rebels
she fought alongside Jedi like Kanan
Jairus and Ezra Bridger but it's
interesting how she says I don't know
what they told you about us grogu lived
throughout most of that history and
bogoton isn't that much older than grogu
bukitan fights a few alamites using her
lassos and her circular arm Shields
slaying these guys even without the
darksaber and on the last kill she looks
back to the camera and she asked grogu
do you think your dad was the only
Mandalorian I love this because bogoton
calls denjar and grogu's Dad she sees it
we all see it the captor drains din jarn
of his blood while a little pump Droid
begins sucking out this fluid Boca Don
shoots the pump and engages the captor
lastly in the darksaber and igniting it
interestingly not seeming to struggle
with the weight as much as din did so
should the darksaber be won by combat or
can someone who claims it a different
way still connect with that kyber
Crystal Beau impales him through his
Central organs like Obi-Wan blasting
General Grievous his heart but the
captor detaches from the body and the
head crawls away like a cockroach which
feels like an homage to John Carpenter's
The Thing when the alien detaches to the
head and Sprouts spider legs to crawl
away but bogoton is able to use the
darksaber to slice apart the captor's
larger Droid attachment first taken out
its legs and then beheading it Boca time
makes some punk super din jar in which
so nice didn't insist he must follow his
Creed to find the Living Waters saying
the Creed is all their scattered people
have left bocaton says that their
infighting made all the mandalorians
weak and enabled the Empire to smash
them and again this infighting is really
a tradition rooted in the darksaber
something that according to their
tradition must be won by combat meaning
one Mandalorian has to fight another
Mandalorian to win it fighting in Civil
Wars is just part of their history and
that really has been the curse of their
people so in that regard the darksaber
represents the ultimate Mandalorian
curse it doesn't unite mandalorians it
only divides them so they enter the
mines and bogoton says she actually
visited these Living Waters when she was
a girl she recited these same Creed
words but her was just a theatrical
spectacle that the royal family did as
opposed to something that had any
meaning but for din jarin and for the
armor for the whole watch there is true
magic in these words for Boca time it
was just empty words this is truly what
this episode the minds of Mandalore is
really about are these Minds empty or is
there something inside and in the Living
Waters chamber bogtan reads a mandoa
plaque these mines date back to the age
of the first Mandalore according to
ancient folklore the minds were once
amid the star layer Mandalore the great
is said to obtain the mythical Beast it
is from these legends that the skull
Signet was adopted and became the symbol
of our planet I love it it feels so
educational right as if field trips
would be brought through here but
Mandalore the great is really the
founder of this planet this is a figure
who existed an expanded universe AKA
Legends fiction but has survived in a
Canon it was the first guy who tamed and
rode the mythosar but historically the
mythosar were hunted in an extinction by
the first settlers of Mandalore and died
off long before the great cataclysm that
scorched the planet structurally the end
of this episode mirrors the beginning of
episode 1 of this season a Mandalorian
baptism ceremony interrupted by a large
Beast coming up from beneath the waves
and that's what we see here in this
Living Waters baptism dingarin repeats
the same words but gets cut off at a
specific moment the kid was cut off when
he promised never to take off his helmet
din Jaron was cut off when he said that
these words would be forged in his heart
it's almost like fate always intervenes
to keep people from fully completing the
words of this baptism because the words
themselves are not important yet there
is still some magic to the Mandalorian
lore I love how bogoton turns off her
helmet light to better see din's light
through the Merc but in gooeyness she
misses the mess of mythosaur at first
when she passes it she doesn't notice
until she ascends with din in her arms
she sees a massive Tusk in the eye and a
growl coming through the water as in
Legend the mythosar is gigantic it's the
size of a city and it leaves us with so
many questions how is Amit the Tsar
still alive are they aquatic or
amphibious is it sustained itself on
just alamites another fauna that wanders
into the water did it start small all
and grow into this was it always down
here was it down here on the day of
bocaton's baptism does it know her and
remember her are there more mythosars
and was it seen only by Bo Katan or did
ninja and see it too did both of them
need to be together for it to present
itself circumstantially that is
absolutely true mandalorians needed to
come together and help each other and
save each other for them to find their
ancestral beast but what's interesting
is if din John was passed out if he
didn't see it will he believe her is
this going to be a wedge between them
Boca time Begins the season as a total
skeptic someone who used to put her
faith in reclaiming the darksaber who in
the darksaber failed her she'd lost her
faith but now seeing the mythosar has
given her something greater and older
than the dark saber something truer to
the Mandalorian ancestry to believe in
though Living Waters of Mandalore are
life this actually might be the
turquoise fluid that was poured in the
opening shot of the Season by the
armorer and so we come back to the
mystery of the armor did the armorer
know the mythosar was down here when she
sent din jar into these Waters did she
do that to feed the Beast with the human
sacrifice something she does with many
black sheep from her clan or could this
have been a test by the armorer to see
if the mythosar would present itself to
a worthy dark saber wielder comment down
below with your thoughts reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive and you get supported Instagram and
something from nerd riot.shop follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
into rockstars And subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
foreign